hey Jenna yeah I've been getting this
crazy question that people keep asking
me they like Justine are you doing Veda
so right now Jenna and I are taking the
dog to the groomers he's gonna get a
little haircut at a bath that laughs
stuff going on today furniture that you
see behind me behind me might not be
here we're rearranging doing a little
moving around getting some furniture
next week so stay tuned for that fun
Madi why is Pikachu and Eevee in here
okay yep are you cool
here's his new car bed that we got the
other day it's something new so keeps
taking in his little little car seat
daddy you guys go get pretty you ready
for this Jenna mate I'm not
I'm fine eat groom I'm disgusting oh
he's so hands you're very handsome you
look like a little girl right now though
but that's okay I know honey I'm sorry
you gotta get clean because you're such
a dirty boy should I keep talking to my
sandwich and I'm saying
where's the other half of this peanut
butter jelly the other half please here
I'm still upset that there's only half a
sandwich but what is this
chocolate-covered raisins oh cable word
for the other
movers still aren't here they originally
gave me a time of 8 o'clock and 10 and
then he called back and said oh might be
a clock at 12 apparently said they told
me 8 2 4 8 to 4 is a really long time
Jenna I just had to pick up the pup I'm
editing a video right now
Justine are you doing beta from the
various different filters I'm the
furniture that I have I'm actually
donating it to it's this like women's
shelter place so it's pretty cool
because people that actually would need
the things can have the things this is
the guest room
also known as Jenna's room I don't even
know what's going on I'm not sure what's
happening I'm just sitting waiting
patiently clearly sitting and waiting
patiently I'm not sure what's been going
on but like the past couple of days like
everybody's been really sassing me up
like why is everybody being like so mean
not necessarily like mean just I don't
know is mercury in retrograde again let
me google it it's gotta be Mercury's
definitely in retrograde
August 30th to September 22nd well we're
a little early
mercury is definitely a little bit early
in its retrograde timeframe check out
your zodiac profile Mercury retrograde
and zodiac signs let's see if Pisces
it's clear with that I don't know what
does means I'm just trying to find
excuses for why things are like they are
sometimes like if something's like going
your way find out why I guess I'll
finish it in this video it was like four
or five
he's so computed so compute like what do
we do general like who do I think is
evaluating I'm Martha Stewart or what
not
Hey look a ton of the police it's really
moving that's all
yep I should measure this my ocean okay
ready to go get a carpet I'm making this
black carpet here I know my battery is
gonna die what do I do the lack of
carbon I think the waters in your PC yes
am i right
somebody said to me yesterday and one of
my vlogs they're releasing that's really
crazy how did you make the whole
background of your video black and white
and then they wrote back or sit and he
might have been the same comment that
like oh that's just cuz everything in
the background grayscale I think the dog
couch try not to go I also had this
discussion in a previous blog did you I
don't watch videos but yeah he doesn't
like it Maddie should get rid of your
couch oh my guess that's a yes huh I
have no idea where all my camera
batteries are this is not charged
so I'm now logging on my GoPro because
either camera okay put your page really
good boy such a great listener anyone's
not yeah cool yeah look at this
what are we what are we doing here on
yeah am i doing beta I don't know have
you posted every day right now we are
going to look at some carpets I want to
get a nice black carpet for the office
I'm not sure if I have said that more
I've repeated myself because you did
really hungry and I can
thank straight when I get really hungry
I am very hungry
remember that peanut butter and jelly
sandwich I ate yeah where was the other
half of it who's so tiny pequeno it's
actually a really good peanut butter
jelly sandwich that's why I wanted like
I could have eaten five halves which
would have been like two and a half
sandwiches is there a grand opening of
something somewhere is that where you
guys are going with all that camping
supply you guys are definitely going to
sleep outside a rug in is g-wagen a
little bit smaller I measured it and
it's an 8 P so we'll see if it's gonna
work hey maybe we can find a couch but
we have a poor Emma it's gonna close
let's go oh my gosh it's great the dog
would absolutely love it so I'm looking
for like a million black-ish type dark
grey ish rug for diseases
oh just could all three of us fit here
nicely let's see last year
next there that is here
one two O's myself and my other couch
with the ten feet ten of my feet I like
having to El Rey now because that you
can add like you can actually get have
more people oh my god
I think maybe they have this little
shirt you're not having much luck at all
no but I'm really enjoyed their doing
you see me too
tired clearly working this looks too big
she's a mushy and she said it guys you
ever just like it's super emotional he's
gonna cry I think I'm PMSing I think
that might be the problem it's not
mercury mercury is non retrograde I'm
PMSing that's it guys you don't
understand what it's like look at this
cute little thing
that was not good we may be little one
more furniture place well it's me I was
all ready for an 8 by 10 rep there was a
nine by 12 not gonna fit in my fit we
have to do some majoring well
it might fit well not concerned about
your car cuz they deliver I don't think
they do
Oh God alright now they have to maybe we
just want it same day with like Matt
punch on that same day really countess
we'll take it now don't die good now
just like don't get hit by I'm not gonna
get my car okay bye I'll see you in a
second I'm going ah so I found a
furniture store as we're driving that
I'm gonna go take a peek at while Jenna
tries to find a place to park
no luck guys guess what we just ordered
wine no Rose I have a few drinks and
then we're gonna go look Pokemon on the
pier it took me 45 minutes to get here
we are going to have fun it was awesome
for moving things and I didn't even move
anything like what we go one end tables
yeah but I've been like cleaning in
supply know be excited oh yeah nothing
is like not it's just everything is a
mess
understand
excellent dinner Friesland Brussels
sprouts and wine having a great day we
have our veggies like fried
for a coffee bean because we need coffee
because we need to go hunt Pokemon sign
out what's telling me you guys can't see
it but this peer is completely there
hacked with people every Thursday they
call concerts and stuff so it's really
really really busy you see ah so let's
go back we can come here tomorrow
morning I'm gonna hunt Pokemon and then
yeah all right a lot of people not worth
it and mine also is not logging in so
I'm quite upset about your little small
version we haven't lost my mind
everything is not right Maddie Maddie
cover up your private parts I'm going to
start making you wear pants you're an
actor uh me 15 plus I feel very violated
me and look at that butt ba ba ba oh
he's not happy about me grabbing his
butt like that I'm sorry Jackie
I just violated my little man oh I'm
sorry
Oh miss miss miss I love this little dog
so much
I think you're watching today's vlog
hope you enjoyed it it was really crazy
cuz like Jenna earlier was like hey are
you doing Veda you never answered us
would you say you never answered us what
do you what do you mean are you doing it
doing what yeah doing Veda yeah am i
doing Veda yes you keep asking you but
never answering the question
no she's talking about you never has a
question are you going to the ball here
no go to bed
what are you there but stop asking me
these questions I don't have answers for
you thank you now I'm taking fun of me
because I said did you just come to Dave
& Buster's scheme listen Matt I'm hungry
you can eat I want to eat too